le gaspillage alimentaire se produit un
peu partout à l'épicerie dans les
transports dans notre propre frigo et
aussi à la ferme on estime qu'entre 20
et 30 % des fruits et légumes qui
poussent finiront pas recourir aux
champs ou dans un tas de compost
une façon de limiter ses pertes c'est de
faire de la transformation voici donc le
portrait d'une femme qui en a fait sa
mission et qui sait créer du même coup
un boulot assez inusité
[Musique]
aujourd'hui je m'en vais au jardin du
village à caplan et une ferme maraîchère
raison une belle grosse récolte comme en
anglais je vais faire des cornichons
avec ceux des conditions fermenté et
ensuite on va faire du kimchi est
peut-être un peu de choucroute ça va
dépendre du temps que j
myriam larouche tremblay s'est lancé il
ya deux ans dans la transformation de
légumes bio comme elle vit en gaspésie
près de la baie des chaleurs et qu'ici
les fermes sont très éloignées les unes
des autres
elle a décidé d'aller sur place
transformer les légumes sa cuisine
industrielle
c'est son camion nos premières avec un
camion qui dépasse 4500 kg de pnbv avec
des bonbonnes de propane pigeot par jeu
l'opère commercialement donc je suis une
exploitants de véhicules lourds il
s'agit d'un ancien camion de livraison
qu'elle a entièrement modifiée avec
l'aide de quelques amis qu elle a même
isolé contre le froid pour allonger la
saison de production
myriam ne voulait pas avoir de
génératrices à cause du bruit et de la
pollution
son électricité elle apprend à la ferme
où elle s'installe dans le fond mon
camion c'est comme si c'était une
cuisinière je me branche dans une prise
de cuisinière qui est installé chez
l'agriculteur
[Musique]
pour le producteur maraîcher étienne
gauthier le camion de myriam est bien
pratique il permet d'écouler les légumes
invendables et les surplus on est des
copains de cour des comptes prône une
suite généraux on devrait arracher ce
plan la semaine prochaine les concombres
qui porte on pourra pas les
commercialiser
parce qu'ils sont pas conformes mais là
on a l'option par exemple envoyer à
transformation fait qu'ils vont passer
pour faire des marinades la relique de
la torah fermentation est le terreau y
en a quand même mais on parle de
plusieurs centaines c'est pas quelques
milliers de lucile légumes qui seraient
autrement pas vendu comme matière
première pour faire un produit ça fait
sens de pouvoir le vendre en circuit
court
au lieu que ce qu'on achète des produits
qui viennent de loin qu'on peut s'en
faire avec ce qui se trouve ici
ce mois c'est ce que ça correspond je me
sens dans mon dans mon élément l'anal
une de ses passions ce sont les aliments
fermentés le chien en train de faire des
cornichons l'actos fermenté c'est un peu
l'ancêtre de la marina en fait c'est une
technique de conservation qui existaient
bien avant les frigos il ça se fait par
la magie
du légume frais puis du sel qu'on ajoute
la note qu'elle utilise vient lui aussi
de la ferme en fête l'agriculteur on a
planté tout un rang expressément pour
elle on a planté de la sarriette pour
les herbes sali on a de la coriandre
pour la salsa
la note court les cornichons sans règle
tout cuisinière vous devez avoir rendent
à naître pour faire étonnamment ce
qu'elles cuisinent ce sont des surplus
planifier les agriculteurs savent à
l'avancé quels seront les légumes de
trop à quel moment de l'année
ça permet de prévoir les recettes et les
condiments trois fermes vraiment un
partenariat avec l'acs lesquels on a
planifié pendant l'hiver de faire des
produits cet été et à l'automne
salut les produits sont vendus par la
firme elle-même
myriam larouche tremblay n'est rémunéré
que pour son travail elle fournit même
les étiquettes la vente des petits pots
devrait cette année fournir à peu près
5% des revenus de la ferme de l'argent
qu'il serait pratiquement impossible de
générer autrement avec la gestion
courante des affaires d'entreprise la
mise en marché on a le kiosque à gérer
les marchés publics s'il fallait en plus
qu'on fasse de la transformation une
deux ou trois journées par semaine je
vois mon jour programmant pour voyager
comme myriam tient à utiliser le plus
possible des ingrédients locaux
elle développe des recettes originales
ce qui me chie par exemple une sorte de
choucroute coréennes qu'elle a adapté à
la sauce gaspésienne les opinions des
carottes des seyssois du verre donnions
des poireaux les coréens ne mettent ce
qu'ils ont sous la main
nous on a vu la belle maurice allais qui
qui plaît aux gaspésiens gaspésie donc
on met de la morue salée de dans
d'autres elle développe ses recettes
avec les agriculteurs eux-mêmes pour la
relire ici je suis parti la recette la
mère de sonia qui est la propriétaire
ici elle aimait sa religion mais on
avait envie de changer un petit peu la
texture donc je suis parti puis aussi
avec ce que je connais mon expérience
les procédés que j'utilise on est avec
une religion qui est unique
ce soit par exemple elle va chez une
autre de ses clientes avec laquelle elle
développe une nouvelle sauce elle a
essayé trois recettes
ça c'est la première c'est sauce tomate
et ou qui n'y fermenté avec ton basly
python eyed peas continuent tout plein
de bonnes bases il est vraiment bonne
un peu acide ouais c'est celle avec le
zouk ai dit qu'on avait réduit la portée
en corée avant de l'étranger mais en
pure y est encore un peu mais moins que
les autres c'est vraiment faire de
l'éducation un petit peu de sucre et
[Musique]
myriam cherche déjà à diversifier ses
sources de revenus elle donne des
ateliers par exemple
son entreprise est jeune et l'avenir est
ouvert je ne sais pas peut-être que je
devrais un moment donné accompagné mon
camion d'un genre de bâtiment avec des
chambres de fermentation des choses
comme ça pour pouvoir laisser seul au
but le camion deviendrait une jambe
d'école la conseillère ou à un genre de
laboratoire mobile
ce qui est certain c'est qu'elle n'a pas
l'intention d'abandonner ce principe je
veux pas grossir à un devant et importé
ville des légumes d'autres régions pour
pouvoir suffire à la demande produit je
veux vraiment que ça reste avec les
légumes sont produits localement puis il
y en a énormément
j'aimerais pouvoir tout les transformer
[Rires]
[Musique]